we also have dystopian news not just
from the world of donald trump's taxes
but from the world of the supreme court
because donald trump has indeed
nominated the supreme court
uh to the supreme court the seventh
circuit judge
who we reported to you last week as the
front runner
her name is amy coney barrett i have
clips
from this completely authoritarian
nightmare event
during which donald trump nominated amy
coney barrett but i do want to remind
you of a few things before we get to
that
last week in my segment about amy coney
barrett
i told you that she is not merely a
federalist society type
she's not merely an anti-abortion type
she's not merely a
it's all for god even the legal system
type
i told you that she's part of a cult
called the people of praise
which is reminiscent of the cult that
margaret atwood describes in the
dystopian novel a handmaid's tale
and i got a few emails over the weekend
from people saying you know david you
have to apologize
apologize because people of praise
was not actually the inspiration for
handmaid's tale
that was fake news and you fell for it
so let me clarify now no no
no i didn't fall for anything i was very
much aware
last week that handmaid's tale was
inspired by a different group called
people of hope
i never said last week that people of
praise was the inspiration for
handmaid's tale
i told you that there are some
interesting overlaps
barrett is part of people of praise and
there are
reminiscent elements of people of praise
that we see in handmaid's tale for
example
people of praise previously referred to
women in the cult
as handmaids now they've since changed
the name a people of praise believes in
the subjugation of women
in households as a matter of default
that's reminiscent of a handmaid's tale
yes people of praise was not what
inspired margaret atwood's book
but i never said that people of praise
was what inspired margaret atwood's book
so please stop asking me for apologies
that don't make any sense
now on to the event donald trump
announced that yes
amy coney barrett is his nominee to
replace ruth bader ginsburg
putting in place a possible justice
who would close many of the doors that
ruth bader ginsburg
opened and left opened behind her it's
tragic
it's nothing short of tragic so let's
get into it donald trump here
reading from a teleprompter the same
type of teleprompter he slams joe biden
for using making it official
amy coney barrett is his nominee to
replace
rbg today it is my honor to nominate
one of our nation's most brilliant and
gifted legal minds
to the supreme court she is a woman
of unparalleled achievement towering
intellect
sterling credentials and unyielding
loyalty to the constitution judge
amy coney barrett
so this really is horrible this is the
exact
opposite of the type of person we should
have on the court you look at other
countries
and you see other countries moving
forward we're moving backwards we're
putting in more people who are against
abortion people who believe that
civil government is a system meant to
serve religious interests amy coney
barrett
uh saying that reportedly when she spoke
to notre dame
at notre dame this could not be more
dystopian and toxic
and the entire event was whacked donald
trump here without
even a semblance of irony and no iota of
ironing
irony urges lawmakers to refrain
from personal attacks
[Music]
i further urge all members of the other
side of the aisle to provide judge
barrett with the respectful and
dignified hearing
that she deserves and frankly that our
country deserves
i urge lawmakers and members of the
media to refrain from
personal or partisan attacks and the
stakes for
our country are incredibly high
yeah donald trump who's been saying
sleepy joe biden has dementia and troop
took drugs before his debate with bernie
and the same donald trump that attacked
meghan markle last week
that donald trump is saying don't make
personal attacks
against amy coney barrett here is
barrett
confirming that she is in line with the
ideology of
the late right-wing supreme court
justice
antonin scalia absolutely horrifying
and given his incalculable influence on
my life
i am very moved to have members of the
scalia family here today
including his dear wife maureen
i clerked for justice scalia more than
20 years ago
but the lessons i learned still resonate
his judicial philosophy is mine too
so as i said last week i do not believe
that at this point we have any way to
stop this
but we still do have things we can stop
like another four years of donald trump
this ship may have sailed
if the republicans want to it's become
clear
because there are only two republicans
that said they would not
vote to confirm a supreme court justice
at this time
if they have the votes they've they've
had the votes now we'll see how the
confirmation hearings go you still do
the confirmation hearings for a reason
but what we can stop is trump getting
more supreme court justices uh clarence
thomas
is not a spring chicken at this point it
is likely that
one maybe two supreme court justices
would be replaced
during the next presidential term i
don't want donald trump getting those
selections
i don't know if you do but from what
we're seeing so far i don't think
anybody should
let me know your thoughts let me know
what you think the strategy should be
from here
through the election i'm on twitter at d
pacman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached
out to them about being a sponsor i've
tried tons of different face masks this
year like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over 150 dollars you can
get there by going
to davidpakman.com slash mask the link
is under this video
and you can save 20 on everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david